DEMOCRATS AND MEDIA SERVANTS
IS THAT WHEN DEMOCRATS FEAR
ABOUT SOMETHING IT'S MORE
ABOUT THE EXACT SAME THING
DIVERSITY AND COMPASSION WHEN
THEY ARRIVE ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD PEOPLE SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND LOCKDOWN THAT
HURTS WORKING AMERICANS AND
HELP THE RICH AND OF COURSE
CLIMATE AND THE PRIVATE JETS.
JOHN KERRY OR WHATEVER.
WHAT ARE WE TO MAKE OF THE
MAIN FOCUS OF THEIR SCREAMING
THESE DAYS?
>> THEY ARE A THREAT TO OUR
VERY DEMOCRACY.
>> THAT OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> EXTREME THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> ATTACKING OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> OUR DEMOCRACY.
STEVE: REPUBLICANS ARE THREAT
TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
REALLY?
DIDN'T THEY PUSH EARLY VOTING
TO NULLIFY THE ELECTION
CAMPAIGN AND PROTECTING
INCUMBENTS SENDING OUT BALLOTS
JUST AFTER LABOR DAY WHICH
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN IN TWO
MONTHS SOMETHING WILD LIKE
DEBATES BETWEEN THE
CANDIDATES.
SORRY YOU CANNOT CHANGE YOUR
VOTE.
TO RATE IT IS EARLY VOTING.
YOU ARE POLITICAL OUTSIDER TO
POLITICS TO GET YOUR NAME OUT
THERE WHEN VOTER START TO PAY
ATTENTION SORRY TO ME EARLY
VOTING.
DO REPUBLICANS DO THAT?
NOW WE KNOW WHY.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE
REPUBLICANS CLOSE WELL.
>> THAT'S WHY DEMOCRATS WANT
EARLY VOTING IS NOT ABOUT
SAVING OUR DEMOCRACY BUT THEIR
POLITICAL SKIN.
IT'S PROBABLY THE MOST ANTI-
DEMOCRACY LEGISLATION EVER PUT
BEFORE THE U.S. CONGRESS NANCY
PELOSI NOTORIOUS HR ONE THAT
KAMALA HARRIS HAD TO USE THE
FILIBUSTER AND ALL THOSE THAT
WOULD IMPOSE EARLY VOTING
EVERYWHERE.
EVEN THOUGH THE 16 -YEAR-OLD
ARE ILLEGAL TO VOTE
NATIONWIDE.
THE BAKER COMMISSION SAID IT
WAS THE MOST VULNERABLE.
AND IT WOULD EXTEND VOTE
COUNTING BE ON ELECTION DAY
THIS IS THE MASSIVELY
OVERREACHING FEDERAL LAW WOULD
UNDERMINE MOST STATES JUST
BECAUSE ALL OF THAT WITH THE
ASSAULT ON OUR DEMOCRACY AND
THEN ON TOP OF ALL THAT AND
THEN THE BANANA REPUBLIC
ATROCITY OF VALID HARVESTING.
AND THOSE OF THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO ARE PAID POLITICAL
OPERATIVES GOING DOOR TO DO -┘-
DOOR TO DOOR TO HELP THEM FILL
OUT THE MAIL AND THEN NOT ONLY
DO THEY THINK IT'S OKAY THEY
WANT TO MAKE IT AVAILABLE IN
EVERY STATE.
JUST CUT OUT THE MIDDLEMAN
MAKING THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE AUTOMATIC WINNER OF
EVERY ELECTION.
>> ONE CANDIDATE AFTER ANOTHER
REFUSING TO EVEN DEBATE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE STATE
COMPTROLLER RACE IN THE SAME
THING WITH THE STATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR THE USELESS
MACHINE POLITICIAN IN CHARGE
NOT EVEN ELECTED IN THE FIRST
PLACE THESE DEMOCRATS HATE
DEMOCRACY UNLESS IT DELIVERS
THE ONLY ACCEPTABLE OUTCOME IN
THEIR VIEW THAT EMPOWER THE
DEMOCRATS THEY HAVE THE
MINDSET OF A TOTALITARIAN
ONE-PARTY STATE LISTEN TO DHS
SECRETARY LAST SUNDAY FROM
9/11 ANNIVERSARY.
>> WE SEE THE EMERGING THREAT
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS OF
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EXTREMIST ANTIGOVERNMENT
SENTIMENT FALSE NARRATIVES
PROPAGATED ON THE ONLINE
PLATFORMS.
>> ANTIGOVERNMENT SENTIMENT?
NOW A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EXTREMIST AMERICA WAS BUILT ON
ANTIGOVERNMENT SENTIMENT AND
NOW DEMOCRATS WANT TO
CRIMINALIZE IT.
DID THEY REALIZE HOW CHILLING
THIS IS WHEN THEY SAY
DEMOCRACY THEY MEAN POWERFUL
THAT'S WHY I DIDN'T THINKS
NOTHING OF GIVING HALF A
TRILLION DOLLAR BRIBE TO RICH
COLLEGE KIDS WHY THEY COLLUDE
WITH BIG TECH FOR POLITICAL
OPPOSITION AND CRUSHED JUST TO
THE VOICES AND GERRYMANDER
WHILE COMPLAINING ABOUT
GERRYMANDERING BEEN RIGGED THE
VOTING RULES PERMANENTLY IN
THEIR FAVOR WHILE ACCUSING
REPUBLICANS OF DEMOCRACY AND
THEN THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO GO AFTER THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS HOW DARE THEY TALK
ABOUT UNDERMINING DEMOCRACY
THAT IS WHAT THEY THEMSELVES
DO EVERY SIN